this is the 63rd consecutive year you
can watch the Masters right here on CBS
and Jim Nantz of CBS Sports has been
covering it for the past thirty three of
those years he is with us from Augusta
Jim good morning and so good to see one
of the most special places in the world
I was honored to just come from there so
tell us that you were here yeah so tell
us tiger woods a big story lines yeah
there's a lot of great storylines and in
the places abuzz to see what Tigers
going to do is practice rounds this week
have really been eye popping - he's made
three Eagles the last three days on the
par fives here and you know we've seen
this comeback far exceed anyone's
loftiest expectations as he's contended
a couple of times in just a handful of
tournaments since basically sitting his
golf game dormant for a couple of years
and in his back of course he's won here
four times and everybody's anxious to
see what he's going to be able to do
today and I think he's going to play
well they keep saying Jim that he has a
new attitude on and off the course have
you seen or heard about that yourself
everybody's talking about that gal it's
just he seems to be in a really good
place with his life and it's wonderful
to see that you know he's happy he's
supportive of his fellow pros he played
a practice run the other day with Phil
Mickelson who a lot of people used to
think there was such fierce competitive
rivals the idea they go out and and and
and play his buddies in the practice
round that's happening now and I think
it typifies that right now Tiger is kind
of in a different place mentally he
seems to be enjoying the journey a
little bit more he's a little more open
with everyone he's dealing with the
media the fans again his fellow
competitors and I would expect that a
lot of this adds up to Tiger having a
very enjoyable week here now he's going
to run into the best of the best of
course everybody's here and it's been I
heard
Norah talking about it earlier it has
been a remarkable year for the game
because the upper echelon players are
winning and I mean there's like they're
one at a time you're checking off the
box Bubba Watson wins Rory McIlroy wins
Phil Mickelson Jason Day Justin Thomas
I mean they're all coming here with
their games in in peak form so it's it's
gonna be great to see you've said Jim
that this may be the most anticipated
masters of the three decades that you've
been covering them why is that what else
should we be looking for
I think that's primarily John it speaks
to the fact that I can't ever recall
where really the top players in the
world all come here feeling like that
they're ready to win this thing
there aren't a lot of issues last year
take Dustin Johnson who currently is
number one in the world
he had a great lead up to the Masters
and then he slipped down a staircase on
the eve of the tournament was unable to
play we got everyone healthy and their
games are all system go it's it's
looking like you know the best of the
best or are ready to take it to Sunday
and then see who can handle the back
nine pressure and Jim finally what an
announcement yesterday from Augusta a
chairman Fred Ridley about a women's
tournament there yay it's it's a
wonderful thing I mean it's really truly
it's it's great for the game it's great
for women's golf they're gonna have the
Augusta Women's Amateur Championship
starting next year it'll be on the
weekend before this tournament and it
just speaks again to how the club has
made such a commitment for the future of
the sport they did this a few years ago
with the Latin America Amateur the Asia
Pacific Amateur and then the drive chip
and putt and now we're gonna have a
tournament here that is it just
instantly becomes one of the biggest
tournaments and in women's amateur golf
and I just thought it was a fantastic
thing yeah growing the game calling the
game alright Jim oh it's good for CBS
this goes back a long time you know as
you said sixty plus years and we really
look forward to presented to everybody
this weekend it's going to be special
and I look forward to hearing you Jim
Nantz I could listen you read the phone
book
you can stream CBS Sports coverage of
the entire 82nd masters tournament just
visit CBS sports.com and CBS Sports will
broadcast the action starting on
Saturday with that music at 3:00 Eastern
right here on where guys cbs13 does the
most amazing job I got to see something
incredible and I missed you guys the
last three days but I come back bearing
gifts got you some presents thank you no
this is from Berkman's which is a nice a
tagline jacket no I guess you have
jacket that was it's yellow
no I like yellow I like it for you you
know I thought it was a picture frame
I'm like oh okay favorite no I like it
North thank you very much you're very
welcome be where I'll go with it and
that's a special logo that green logo is
very special to offer you all right and
today on the CBS works morning podcast
CBS sports golf analyst Ian baker-finch
joins us from Augusta National Golf Club
he previews the Masters and gives us his
pick for this year's dark horse plus his
thoughts on whether Tiger Woods or Rory
McIlroy Phil Mickelson can take home the
green jacket this year find it on iTunes
or Apple's podcast app you are watching
CBS this morning